uh and also
um
speaking of legendary celtics bill
russell there's this
huge auction going on friday in boston
um
bill russell is auctioning off hundreds
of items uh you're talking trophies
you're talking rings you're talking
uh
cards your cards
warm-ups jerseys
it's going to benefit
mentor a group he's very close with in
the boston celtics united for social
justice
so that's all happening december 10th
wow front auctions
doing the honors
oh wow when we had a chance
to uh to speak with uh bill russell
earlier tonight and you know he's got a
million stories and he took us way way
way back for this one
you know when i was
in junior high school
and
my mother had died so my father my
brother and i
and i
had it my father gave me a choice of
where i wanted to go to high school
now my brother was all city at oakland
tech
and he said to me at dinner one night
do not
tell anybody that you're my brother
because you can't play
and
ruin my reputation
that is a classic uh and 11 rings later
i guess his brother was wrong he did
okay i tell you what though that that
i probably would like to have some of
that collection because he's been great
to me all these years
he should for what he what he's done for
civil rights in this country is
unmatched
him and ali
or and will always be to me my heroes as
far as that goes i said
it's easy to be a social justice guy now
when you got 100 million dollars you're
making 30 40 million dollars a year but
those guys did all the heavy lifting
back in the day i think i i think i
might look at that auction and bid on
something i'm with you and i would have
liked to seen the item before the
auction because you know i would like to
take
take some of that stuff off their hand
you know to be able to have all 11 of
his rings nobody's out bidding me on
that one
wow
i tell you what
that that would be i mean you're the
richest person on this up here no it's
[ __ ] hurtful
he says
he says well i know some other i would
like to not like him like you don't know
them oh jesus listen to him they
wouldn't even let him
i know michael jordan tiger wood they
got more money than shaq and
the thing that was off limits the thing
that he would not part with was the
presidential medal of freedom that he
got from yeah
for president obama you can yeah